oh what about the celebration though oh  that was such a cool moment like  um yes i wish i tackled him in the  corner  yeah but i was meant to be he scored a  try on me  and you know that celebration was was  pretty funny  i was a little bit rattled i had to  bounce back  and get on with it that's such a cool  attitude that you've got a lot of guys  would just completely fire up there  but you just took that on the chin and  you copped it like a champion and you  kept playing and obviously still led the  blues to victory that day  yeah i had i i was rattled especially  because the main man  touching my head was scrafton who was  the blue the previous year so  quite ironic  um but now it's funny i love the bands  with kalsi